our attentions many people's attention
to look into these problems to look into
the questions about the ground water
contribution so how much fresh water
discharged to the ocean through the
underground systems yes so you know our
measurements at the beach very localized
but ultimately related to that big
questions big questions that concerning
the global hydrological cycle someone's
opinion may contradict yours what my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we if what is the
nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Sathyan we are on-site at the
beautiful West Lake University in
Hangzhou China we are now going to be
talking about environmental hydrology we
have dr. Ling Li joining us on the show
hi Lee hi Alan thank you so much for
coming on our show really appreciate it
pleasure we're so excited for this
episode for those who don't know Ling's
background he's professor in van
environmental hydrology at West Lake
University School of Engineering focused
on mathematical modeling of complex
environmental systems and you can find
the links in the bio below all right
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions we like asking our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world it's such a big
questions I don't even know where to
stop but I read you know quite a few
news articles about the big van around
the world now on BBC reports about the
global warming discussions the in the UN
summit but prior to that they were very
very soon
protests around the world by the young
people and of course this is quite
related to my research work climate
change has always been kind of the drive
or what do we do so in a way I was very
pleased to see it but I think the world
has been undergoing changes very rapid
changes changes I'm not sure all for
good and of course in China that that
you know those changes occur to a much
greater extent also at a much faster
pace I often get asked about what I
think about China's and develop Allen
and even in the scientific research
areas and I use the word fast always so
you know that rapid development around
the world I would say has put so much
pressure on our resources and our
environment as a whole climate change is
becoming more and more evidence there is
there is a consensus I would say not
just within the scientific community but
also in the general public that this is
becoming a big challenge perhaps the
biggest we're facing now the whole
humanity and
and and and and so you asked me about
the directions of the world I reckon we
are facing this challenge we have to do
something about it
my research looking at these
hydrological processes in various
systems has a lot to do with climate
change and in many ways we aim to look
for ways to better assess the impact and
look for ways of dealing with the impact
medications or self adaptations of the
systems yes yes just yesterday we were
talking to catching on the show about
sustainable industrialization and
circular economics and this is why I
love Westlake there's so many of these
different components tackling it from a
bioengineering and sustainability
standpoint tackling it from an
environmental hydrological standpoint
we're sure we're gonna unpack today on
the show I really appreciate the focus
on taking care of this planet that
sustains us that's such an important
critical part of our life so how about
when you were a kid and how you even got
interested in the environment how you
got interested in science what were
those main in impact factors that got
you interested
it was almost accidental I would say I
mean what I had in my mind about
environmental science and engineering
was quite ecological I like math and I
like physics and I had an idea that the
degree program' I chose and that was
offer at Shanghai University or top
engineering University in China
I thought the program was oriented
towards ecology more than pollutions
problems with we we did all I end up
doing a lot so somehow you know I went
to the program with that idea but it
turned out the program wasn't like that
at all
I initially lost a little bit interest
in my study with a big focus on the
design of water treatment plants and so
on
of course it's it's very important and
it's a major research field you know in
in environmental engineering but you can
see my pursue of that interest to look
at ecosystem has been ongoing so the
work I'm doing now physical you know
processes and and so on there's a lot to
do with the eco health of the
environment so ultimately I want to see
how water maintain you know the
ecosystems and how the degradation of a
coastal wetland may be linked to the
change of the flow regimes it may be
linked to sea level rise
but of course through the modifications
of perhaps the the flow and sought
transport or the flow and change of soil
conditions such as aeration conditions
which will affect the plant growth and
distributions and so on in a coastal
wetland so let's jump into this so this
is big for us to understand because we
don't typically think about the ocean
land interface and interactions being
something that we want to dive deeper
into studying many people just walk on
the beach but they don't actually think
about how the ocean and land interface
in a very complex way right at that
region and how the hydrological cycle
deals with with that so over the last 20
or so years you post you know you did
your PhD at the University of Western
Australia and then you've been
specifically a lot of your times been at
the University of Queensland since 2002
to 2018 so 16 years and you were being
doing senior lecturing and also then
professing directly starting in 2005
okay so during that time you were really
deep in working on this submarine
groundwater discharge and that
incorporates oscillating groundwater
flow and the circulation driven by tides
and waves so let's start talking about
this complex environmental ecosystem and
how exactly you've spent the last couple
of decades just diving deep into
understanding that and what can be
[Music]
especially what can what we can take
away as like a big picture understanding
of what's actually happening mm-hmm well
you mentioned you know the beach
environment which we go to an indoor
enjoy our time there
but it's true a lot of the time we
wouldn't go to the beach to think about
the groundwater system underneath at all
and yet you know you experience waves
these oceanic oscillations they are
clearly visible and in fact that's part
of the fun right we have at the beach
and yet for groundwater researchers for
long we have pretty much overlooked the
impact of these oceanic oscillations on
the groundwater system so the classic
classical view of groundwater flow in
the coastal aquifer is based on the
assumptions of Aesthetic sea levels with
these oscillations neglected completely
we we looked into this starting from
2006 with a PhD student project we
measured the groundwater flow in the
intertidal zone of a beach in a great
details involving measurements of
hydraulic had conditions salinity
distributions over many tidal cycles
with the tidal oscillations resolved so
that means the measurements were taken
at a relatively high frequency
intertidal signals were measures and
from that we pick up of course ground
water responses to the title
oscillations but more importantly it's
the time every
in fact that were showing clearly in the
measurements meaning when you average
the groundwater flow there is a residual
current in the result that indicate the
tide not only induces oscillations of
groundwater flow it produces a
persistent flow that drives groundwater
circulating through the upper intertidal
zone near the beach surface and of
course in terms of salinity measurement
we found the presence of a high salinity
song which we call upper say lines on
the importance of this very localized
phenomenon this features of the system
is that it can potentially control the
exit conditions of a transport pathway
for fresh groundwater but also for
what's in that fresh groundwater a lot
of materials coming from the land
largely in the soluble form so this this
is this this localized phenomenon has an
implications for the determinations of
freshwater discharge but also for fluxes
of chemicals that are derived from the
land because you know groundwater and
ocean waters they very different waters
I say one for example has very low
oxygen content and that's groundwater
and the other ocean water has relatively
high oxygen content the two mix
we'll create conditions for reactions
for chemical reaction a lot of chemicals
in a reduced form in groundwater coming
in contact with oxygenated seawater can
get oxidized for example you know we we
were talking about fair assign been
oxidized to ferric iron and and
precipitate so you know a lot of
reactions can take place because of the
mixings induced by the tightly driven
flows and of course you know this
enhanced dispersions of as well yes
let's also then dive into you know did
last since now it's been since October
of 2018 joining Westlake University's
professor of environmental hydrology and
now having seven full-time researchers
here at West Lake and you still have
students and research fellows at the
University of Queensland as well and I
actually really enjoyed this
understanding of how you're probing that
ocean land interface and interactions
because you actually go and do field
trips this is a very fun part to science
I love this part there's such a
beautiful party it's almost like a
holiday you know on the beach a holiday
for you guys for environmental
hydrologist their work their field trip
is literally to the beach yes well you
know the fieldwork I show you I was down
by my students and and they had three
weeks at a beachside near a resort and
and I think for them it was it was a
holiday but it was holiday of a lot of
hard work yes
and let's talk about what exactly people
will see here in this
image that will have embedded you guys
have what are these rods that are inside
of the sand how and what are they
measuring with this ocean land interface
so you know they are sorry they were a
set of sand SERS we put in through these
PVC pipes and they were also SEM pra's
that are inserted two different dabs of
the beach sand within these PVC pipes so
for the sensors we measure the pore
water pressures we measure also the
salinity we measure for some sensors we
were also measuring dissolved oxygen and
in the same time we measure in the same
time we also semper sample waters for
direct measurement of these these are
you know physical physical chemical
parameters including even pH and the aim
is to look at the flow the hydraulic hat
can be determined based on the
measurement of the pore pressures and of
course the complexity here is the
salinity has to be combined in the
calculations has to be combined with the
pressures because gravity here is an
important drive of the flow but then
gravity exists in an environment with
variable density now it's it's a bit
technical but I guess you can think of
buoyancy force as perhaps the analogy
here if you have different density of
course the force balance would be
different right and therefore in the
calculation of the hydraulic had the
density fare has to be taken into
account
nevertheless with the pressure
measurements and the salinity we can
calculate the hydraulic head the
gradient of the hydraulic head will
indicate the flow the ground would have
float in this case of course arm could
be just pour water mix pour water with
both freshwater and seawater involved
and the salinity measurement is not
trivial using electrical conductivity
probe sometime requires a lot of
calibrations
in that environment and do measurement
is also not trivial remember this is in
the sand I a lot of these probes they
are built for clear water so indeed in
the pipe we had to you know design a
measurement chambers at different depths
again in order to measure the
representative local salinity dissolve
oxygens
fairly accurately and of course to
ensure the in search of measurements
using these sensor these probes we also
sample water for independent
measurements to validate the
measurements the data of of these
sensors collected by these sensors and
the measurement were taken over the
tidal periods in fact I think we did it
for for one particular field campaign we
actually took the measurement over a
period of three weeks covering the
spring and neap cycle so very intensive
very intensive but then these
measurement provider pictures of how you
know the local flow processes involving
recycling sea waters and then fresh
water discharge the discharge of water
coming from the land to the oceans and
even circulations of sea water in the
lower salt water way driven by the
density gradients how these three
different kind of flow regimes interact
yeah so I think it's necessary and in
indeed our measurement our initial
measurement this you know involving a
lot of hard work at the end kind of
provide the pictures of that complex
ground water flow systems yes yes I like
how you call this a global hydrological
cycle that's happening
I like how you showed me this really
good Jif that was being in that we can
embed here where it's as though when the
two
you need this ocean land interface
there's so much complexity happening
there and you can you can simulate out
what the tide from the ocean is doing to
that ocean land relationship and you can
you can see how there is this
there's the formation of this saline
plume mm-hmm that occurs and you can see
how there is this meeting this meeting
zone of the freshwater that meets the
ocean water then the complex geo
biogeochemical reaction that's occurring
right there and that zone and how even
further there's also this other really
cool asset that you were showing me that
we can bed here where there's a there's
the relationship of these these
groundwater aquifers that also interplay
at these ocean land interfaces where
there's actually and and even small
earthquakes have a lot to deal with the
way that the rock though the fractures
occur from the aquifers that enable the
groundwater to come up deep aquifers
that we were talking about the aquifer
and how it it's so fascinating how it
literally it you also taught me this
this phrase catchment hydrology mm-hmm
and that there's these these gorgeous
like like fresh water in catchment
plumes that occur in normally like
completely say more saline a say line
area area and and the grass was called
Cogan Cogan grass there's a freshwater
species yeah yeah so you know I guess we
talked about how a beach ground water
system can be complicated by tide waves
and lately
we looked at the impact of the
temperature differences between ocean
water and coastal ground waters and of
course we previously studied how even
the beach morphology the shape of the
beach can also influence how the
groundwater flow in the near shore zone
but the complexity of the groundwater
system itself is also in that the the
aquifer may involve multiple units not
just one shallow aquifer as we just
talked about yes may not just be simply
a sandy aquifer with the beach has been
you know the seaward boundary underneath
they may be confining aquifers confining
units and and the confining unit may be
recharged by a remote source from a
distant area
you set catchment of course it's it's a
very important concept in hydrology
because it tells where the water comes
from and quite often in catchment
hydrology when we do water balance we
assume the groundwater system has the
same the shallow groundwater system has
the same catchment as the surface water
for a lot of the hydrological system of
a lot of river basin this is possibly
quite true
but as I showed you I you know the field
sigh we had in the chansu province in a
reclaimed land area next to the coast
basically north of Shanghai and also
Shanghai that the system clearly is
impacted by not only recharge from the
local area but also a remote water
source which goes through this deep
groundwater aquifer with the leakage
right Wow that goes up wells to the
local surface aquifer and potentially
also discharged directly to the ocean as
well and that will change the
traditional view ideological view based
on you know the classical catchment
water balance here we talk about an
additional water could be large amount
discharged into the oceans yes I think
it you know in deep aquifers and
catchment hydrology is one of one of
them potentially many other complexities
of the ocean land indentations yeah the
the the hydrogeology
itself can be very complex on and and
again that's the challenge and yet we we
have to resolve this in order to
quantify how much ground would actually
discharge to the oceans it is an
important question because this affect
our estimate of the return flow of water
from the land to the oceans
currently the estimate is is largely
based on a river discharge ground water
contribution is assumed to be fairly
small but we'll have more paper
published in Nature in 1996 attracted
our attentions many people's attention
to look into this problems to look into
the questions about the ground water
contribution so how much a freshwater
discharge to the ocean through the
underground systems yes so you know our
measurements at the beach very localized
but ultimately related to that big
questions big questions that concerning
the global hydrological cycles why
should you care about the water cycle
the water cycle is a vital component of
life the fact that we have water on this
planet that is located in just this
perfect habitable zone around the star
that gives us water for life is that
we're made of life that so many that
water sustains us that we drink every
single day that the water cycle itself
the hydrological cycle itself is so
important for us to study to get these
amounts for us so let's let's actually
explain this exact amount so that right
now it's approximated that forty
thousand cubic kilometers of water is
exchanged between the rivers and the
ocean globally annually is an
approximation but that's not taking into
account the ground water that could
these deep aquifers all of these other
potential
styles of ocean land interface and so
for us to get the true picture of that
aspect of our water cycle is a critical
way for us to realize the planet that we
actually live in and on and how if we
get a more clear understanding of our
reality that's one of the most important
things for us to do
yes iets yeah I think your
interpretation is actually fairly
accurate almost accurate the forty
thousand cubic kilometres as the annual
amount of the ball exchange between land
and oceans the estimate is largely based
on River discharge assuming the ground
water contribution is is small but I
think it is an open questions as to how
much you know water is returned from the
land to the ocean through the
groundwater system still not resolved
and it's important to have a good
constraint on that figure I think we
need to know more accurately what is the
amount of water exchanged between the
land and oceans because it is the amount
of water vapor of flux the net flux from
the ocean to from over oceans to
overland roughly it's it's it's a large
percentage it's 35% of the precipitation
on the continents and you can imagine
you know what we see in the river what
we see in the catchment you know
is quite driven by that flux so we need
to know how much it is more accurately
at the moment as already mentioned the
estimate is only based on River
discharge it water is also well water
vapor is a greenhouse gas water vapor
transport provides a key feedback
mechanism for the climate for the
climate change and hydrological cycle
changes and therefore it it is also for
that reason we need to quantify the net
flux more accurately because potentially
you know if we underestimate this flux
you can see that it means we have
underestimate the role played by water
vapor at a very large scale the global
scale right so perhaps that also means
we have underestimated the feedback
played by water vapors as a way either
to modify the climate systems both in
terms of positive or negative feedbacks
you know for a lot of reason we really
need to have a better a better estimate
of this net flux wall exchange between
the land and oceans yes especially the
net flux is here I'm surprised by how
small of a volume the hydrological cycle
right now is predicted to be compared to
the entire volume of the earth of the
earth okay but the water mining is this
odd job in this in this let's say
surface areas or near surface areas
above and below yeah slowly and that's
also where all the life forms okay so
the majority of the life forms exists
exactly so let's let's put it this way
the surface of the planet being 70%
water than 30% land or so and if you
just take into account just the surface
of the planet
I believe 40,000 cubic kilometers is
actually pretty substantial in
comparison to just the surface as in
40,000 cubic kilometers being a part of
the hydrological cycle annually is
actually quite a bit regarding just the
surface you can do it you can do a
conversion of that so if we divide that
volume by the surface area you get some
kind of equivalent either evaporation or
precipitations and then perhaps we can
see how so would be somewhere around 1
but let's let me give you another way of
looking at the significance of that
figure that 40,000 cubic kilometers of
water is equivalent very close to 35% of
the precipitations on the continent yes
you say which is a which is very very
important that's a very own figure just
to make sure that this point is being
communicated is it such a profound one
so ok the Earth's volume is over a
trillion cubic kilometers but I'm not
sure what percent of that volume is on
the surface let's just say
five percent maybe or even less
independent that's probably what you
well what you define as this
near-surface linear CSS is air-sea
rights if it is i guess i said i guess
but okay final time above and below yes
okay um we can I guess some calculation
will have but it would it be 95% or 99%
is located in the actual inner mantle
and outer mantle coracle yeah yeah and
even even the deep cross you cross yeah
deep crust okay so okay so Dan let's
height let's just say and someone can
help us in the comments below and tell
us about these numbers but let's just
say that it's somewhere around 95 or 99
percent of the volume okay so I ran the
calculation a trillion / 95 or so is 10
billion so it's still significant even
if it's 99 your diamond and so ten
billion so then ten billion of the
kilometers cubic kilometers of the
planet are located on the surface or
Koba the edge surface area I think the
volume comparison is not very meaningful
and it might be because it might be look
at here yeah if you well I mean even if
it is I think it is still low but this
ratio doesn't mean much at all
when you look at the hydrological
processes for example you know flow
overland flow and then to the rivers
generating flower and so on all these
processes happen essentially on the land
surface so then how do you calculate the
volume of that area
all right it's a very small volume what
what I'm saying is if you look at what
happened on the land surface as as the
key hydrological processes right when
you have rainfall taking place it
generate Overland flow flow that take
the water to the rivers and then of
course water flowing the rivers which
might generate flat and so on right this
all these processes occur on the land
surface essentially right within the
very very small volume of space so the
volume comparison I think it's not
particularly useful of course you can
argue that you know the the activity
take place not just on the land surface
there will be water going through the
soil and and reach the groundwater and
then you know somehow there will be some
flow activity also underneath and of
course you know you also can think about
the rain as a process rainfall and
precipitate rainfall and also
evaporation as a process that takes
place in the atmosphere as well but
remember at the end right the the the
key processes occur on the land surface
yes so I don't think the volume
comparison is particularly meaningful it
is very true that this large amount of
water exchange Drive the major
hydrological processes on the land
surface yes which is what you see
happening in the rivers in the
catchments everywhere
different scales as well yes so yes yeah
it is important yeah yeah this was
actually really enlightening for me to
dive into that and hopefully for other
people as well because we typically
don't think of the diameter of the
planet the volume of the planet we don't
typically think about what amount of the
the volume of the planet is actually
only along the land surface as well as
the ocean volume and then we don't think
about what volume is moved in the
hydrological cycle globally annually
either and so these things are very
interesting to try and picture what
40,000 cubic kilometers looks like
that's moving in a hydrological cycle
across the planet every single year and
these are all very interesting ways of
perceiving something that just seems to
be not important but is actually
critical to understanding our ecology so
there's of course like you were
explaining as well all of the other
components that actually go into
environmental hydrology and
understanding the ocean land
relationship is in the interface is so
cool and how you guys go on the field
trips to be able to start analyzing this
is so neat I really want you to also
explain how there's more to this that
meets the eye again so when we look at
at dams so we had this example what we
were talking about earlier before we
started with the Three Gorges Dam in
China which I believe is was he was
producing the most energy out of all the
dams up in the planet and was recently
replaced by one that borders about
Brazil and Panama and so I mean the
numbers are crazy a hundred
terawatt-hours per year
Wow and so we don't typically think
about how when you put a dam down how it
affects the ecology of the area and so
they teach us about how putting a dam
here in China at the Yangtze River how
that
environmental hydrological changes okay
now building the dam can potentially
also affect the processes at the ocean
land interface yes because the flow will
be modified by the damned operation as
well but we haven't really look into
that effect yet I was involved in a
project looking at how Three Gorges Dam
operation may inference wetland systems
in two major lakes downstream don'ting
late and poor young late so the
operation of the dam involving different
just discharge patterns or manipulation
of the river discharge prior to and
after the rain season can regulate
caused significant changes of the flow
in the rivers downstream the to effect
are these prior to the rain season the
demo discharge more water than usual to
kind of empathy the reservoir to some
extent to increase its flood mitigation
compassed capacity to increase the
storage and that occur of course prior
to the rain seasons upstream but that
rain season comes later than the Ryan
the rainfall downstream downstream on
the eastern side
you know this whole area is affected by
the eastern Asia monsoon right which
comes from the Pacific so it rains first
for example in poem Lake around May or
late May or June but in the rain
affected by that monsoon system takes
place upstream of the Three Gorges dams
July or late June and therefore this
time lack men when the reservoir
discharged more water this kind of
overlap we have a rainfall in the Lake
area of poor young so potentially the
discharge can cause flooding or can
worsen the flooding in a poem lake area
okay this is the proc in effect we think
that can happen because of the
regulations of the dam on the rivers it
turned out this effect is rather minor
based on our analysis of the data
existing datas but the second effect is
after there the rhine season but then
start to store more water so by reducing
the discharge to raise the water level
in the reservoir for hydropower
generations and that means it will you
know look it will reduce the discharge
and it will lower the river would levels
at the lake at the lake mouth this
lowered water level in the river can
induce can increase the drainage of the
lake water too
the rivers causing potentially a dry
conditions a drought we found based on
the data analysis about a meter of you
know over join or lowering of the lake
water levels because of that effect so
this is quite significant this could
impact on the wetland systems in the
project I was involved in our ecologist
indeed found a trend of these wetland
turning into dry land so you know it is
quite amazing that the impact can be so
visible and manifested in such a way in
such a short period of time and I think
it does give us a warning of running
into this kind of unexpected problems
because of the engineering work it
happens I think quite often we we can
easily overlook this impact totally yeah
when we designed you know the
engineering projects and and so on so
what I have to say you know the tree
called stem overall of course has also
produced positive in fact for example
the power generation you've mentioned
compared to burning fossil fuels yeah
but there's an interest there is a
second step of sustainable energy
advancement that we're going to get to
yeah yeah because they're significant
you can't just put a dam this is really
again just a very important way of
viewing it we were talking about this
again yesterday with catch and just you
can't think that if you're gonna dump
waste water into a river that it's gonna
no downstream effects you got and know
that it's gonna have downstream effects
everything's interconnected same thing
oh let's build a dam here well it's
gonna have ecological and hydrological
effects on the environment not only at
where you put the dam but also
downstream it's gonna have effects and
so humans thinking with this indigenous
principle of seven generations out how
is my dam placement here gonna affect
the environment seven generations down
the line it's just a crucial way of
thinking I think it goes back to almost
you know our initial discussion about
what we're facing now the whole humanity
right things changed so rapidly we have
developed all these technologies that
enable human being to manipulate the
nature so much I mean in the life
science that we start to manipulate life
imagine how frightening that is but of
course you know let's say in in my field
you know not just the rivers but many
other hydrological system have been a
coastline for example has been modified
significantly by humans our urban
development along the coast in Australia
you know this is perhaps the the worst
if I use the word example because 85% of
the population leave along the coast
yeah so it made most changes that pop
that's to the nature that statistic
along the coastline essentially that
statistic might be true across the
planet yeah it might be eighty five
percent of people live along
on the planet yeah that propulsion
probably yeah it's quite so so you I
mean you see this kind of modifications
by us everywhere and I we literally live
on the region of the world potentially
almost nine out of ten of us live on the
region of the world that you study so
damn closely the ocean layer interaction
yeah depending on these statistics right
if it is that such a majority of people
do live in this region let's say eight
out of ten people live coastally within
sixty or so miles of the coast then it
becomes even more and more important for
us to become more and more vigilant and
and scientifically advanced advanced
around our understanding of the ocean
land interaction and relationship the
hydrological cycle around those areas
and also how to decrease our fossil fuel
consumption and increase our sustainable
industrialization so that we can solve
this biggest challenge that the planet
is facing around how humans are are
anthropomorphic
how humans are anthropogenically
affecting the ecosystem that we reside
in and we you know you've been listing
all of these different ways that you're
exploring this and understanding it and
I really I'm just really just deeply
fascinated with this as well will you
give us um two other thoughts that I
want to ask you about or you know when
we saw this graphic in grade school most
of us saw this water cycle graphic that
you have a precipitation that occurs
from the clouds and then you have the
water that flows from the mountains and
from the really
the ocean and then in the ocean the
sunlight evaporate water the sunlight
evaporates water which then rises and
then move to the land to the landing
place it's such a beautiful childhood
but in a way it is that simple
and it is that important as well right
these big cycles so you know the net
flux again is essentially the key
characteristic of that psycho s1 Nets a
flux is where the net flux is the amount
globally that is being moved in the
water over the oceans - yep from over
the oceans the net fluxes is the water
cycle movement the amount of water
that's being moved from from the ocean
over the land yeah my goodness 40,000
cubic kilometres right now is what we
think is the number and it could
potentially be much more and affected by
could be more could be more and it could
but we don't know how much more that's
it could be affected by the the deep
aquifers and and so many other aspects
that we're still understanding yeah net
flux
what a cool to word cuckoo okay what if
we use those words all the time net flux
to words and that if flux and then water
cycle of though yeah yeah yeah I like
that a lot
yeah this is an important environmental
hydrological concept net flux yeah yeah
I love that I love that this is this has
been so enlightening I want to ask you
also about how you guys are using
computer modeling and the mathematical
modeling with simulations and with
trying to see if can we potentially make
like a digital twin of the planet Earth
and then and then see the hydrological
cycle happening on that digital twin
then and then run our calculations like
throw different
variables and situations at it and try
and unpack and how are you guys using
simulations in mathematical models now
full full my work we we built
mathematical models
Phillie well based because these models
are based on the actual processes
so the flow processes or the mass
transport involving a salinity salt
solute and full the scow we're looking
at solving these models these equations
is challenging can be time-consuming but
it's durable so the result I show you
you know what's based on the field side
we measured so at that scale I think
mathematical models very well based or
process based mathematical models can be
developed to assist our understanding
our investigation of these processes and
the phenomena and so on but you also ask
about how we might do this on a global
scale they are models I tell you they
are models combined in atmospheric
processes land hydrological processes
and even ocean circulations really
comprehensive models and and that you
know also aiming to assists
our study of the hydrological cycles and
so on and of course climate change or
climate simulations but these the
problem with these models is that the
resolutions it's impossible to resolve
for example the small-scale processes
and characteristic of the system we were
looking at we are looking at and
therefore these models have to develop
some kind of parameterization of the
small-scale processes in the large-scale
model or formulations and the question
of course then is how valid or how
detailed the permit the parameterization
need to be for example a lot of leant
surface models for the hydrological
processes are simply just based on water
balance for the whole catchment some
could even be bigger than a sub
catchment and it doesn't resolve flows
in the rivers it doesn't resolve
particularly the topography of the
catchment and so on account
computationally impossible and then so
this is the problem with the model in
terms of its formulations in some cases
we know definitely the over
simplification is a problem that can't
be resolved within the model itself and
then of course also to run these models
they are data required some of these
models to consider a different land uses
but then of course to run these models
you do need to have those data they're
not necessarily all available worldwide
some countries can have good data set
but some don't so at the end what you
will find is that the models these
global models they can produce some kind
of prediction of course if you try to
replicate observations from the past you
know the model can be calibrated but you
you you find you know often the result
are subjected to very large degrees of
uncertainties and that's the problem
yeah I think I mentioned already it
doesn't
none of the model predict quite
accurately the amount of waters you know
discharged to the ocean from the land
that is an indications of you know
problems in these models models are very
useful models are often you know very
useful tools for us to investigate these
processes but the challenge of course is
to develop a sound model with enough
details you know resolutions especially
and temporarily to represent the
processes still within the constraint of
assumptions but nevertheless more
compatible to the questions in address
but then as I said models need to be
driven by data which can be a problem
in many applications of these models yes
we need structured data for the models
to be better and we also need the right
computational structure and resources
for the proper simulation process of
something as complex as a hydrological
system I mean this is gonna be a massive
advancement for us once we figure out
how to make a digital twin of the earth
and then analyze it and then be able to
add specific tweak specific variables
and see what happens or add specific
phenomenon like the rise in parts per
million of co2 all this type of stuff
all these types of digital twin
modeling's of the planet a couple quick
questions on the way out that we like
asking our guests how do you think we
can increase collaboration around our
world to meet collaboration happens
almost quite naturally I think you know
we may be assisted by good policies from
founding bodies from the universities
and of course at the national levels
good agreement between countries and so
on but I would say you know science is
something that connects people and
enable them to collaborate almost by its
own power that's what I meant by
naturally but I would say good policies
will enable people to do that better and
at Westlake collaboration is part of
what we do it's everything basically
starting with very very active
communication among ourselves we talk to
each other all the time
exchanging ideas and and of course you
know discussing our work and so on and
that enable within westlake very
cross-disciplinary approach to thinking
identifying problems and to formulating
approaches to to addressing these
problems and carrying out the research
in the actual research I mentioned this
news and idea session a chair by
Professor Ken tree it's it's it's
fantastic mechanisms and at West Lake we
also have good policies to encourage up
you know staff members to collaborate
not only within ourselves but also with
people outside it has a lot to do with
evaluations of the performance you know
these these days University and then
individuals are so driven by metrics for
measuring the performance of academic
these are not particularly good and in
China sometime we try to be so accurate
in allocating you know the credit to
people in the research that we have to
decide only the first author or the
corresponding author will take the
credit and no one else that's clearly
not very helpful for collaboration
so at West lay we we don't care about
that at all we can double or we can
triple count the credit I think that's
the way to go especially since on all of
these advancements in our world the
burden of genius that has
and associated with the advancement of
our healthcare advancements or any
technological advances quantum mechanics
or whatever it is that it's not like
just some first author there's there's
there's a tremendous amount of people
that were parted that partook in that
advancement plus there may be some sort
of like a first author or someone that
carried more of the burden but then
there's thousands of other people that
have continued pushing that advancement
into the world and making it applicable
for us some a couple more questions you
can um dear children I have one son one
son how old's your son a thirteen and
then what would be a skill for your son
and other kids that are being born into
the world that you think is important
for them to know going into the
exponential technology age critical
thinking I'm worried that kids are now
doing so much but thing class so to me
and even for my childhood I had time to
to think well it's it's a problem for
kids but it's also a problem for adults
as well we're becoming so busy and thing
class so I would say critical thinking
is something we need to emphasize in our
education Xin our training being
spoon-fed media and entertainment rather
than enabling ourselves to have long
periods of focused creativity free
association doing nothing yes because if
not when you're busy yeah yeah well
these days if you go to I've more I even
go to a restaurant you see people just
doing things on the mobile phones and so
on in the past we probably would just
stay there you know like this but
somehow probably thinking a couple last
rapid-fire questions to ask what are
your thoughts on the meaning of life
I don't know I've been thinking about
that as well seriously so I don't have
an answer but I think it's a questions
we all have deep in our mind and our
heart so I think sometime that kind of
questions can drive you to some kind of
belief because at the end I don't think
myself or signs can help me to acquire
that kind of question answers to the
question I mean so one of the most
important things to do is to have more
people around the world asking
themselves that question what is the
point of life what is the point of this
grand human experience what is the
nature of this reality that we're in
what is the unique gift that I can bring
forward into the world and if we forget
to ask that question forget to ask
children to think about those car at the
personal level when you talk about
values and so on of course we all have
our value but then I don't think that
itself will give you the answers to the
question you just asked what is life
right or it's the meaning of life so
yeah I don't have an answer for myself
that's why I think believe religious
belief can help with that I am you know
I'm a person who's very kind to seek
answers to that question very very
king-like
yeah yeah totally yeah and last three we
got to do these fast because we have we
have to run what is the role of love in
our world
mmm interesting questions now you know
in China we have a word call your infant
or destiny
now it's if I just interpret it yeah it
could mean that it's a special
relationship so to me you can talk about
how you know at one level of course
let's say between the wife and husband
that love is special that relationship
is special but love of course can be
broader much broader than that but I
also think you know it's a special
relationship you know like what you have
as a special relationship with your work
that's also love and of course even with
colleagues with this university and so
on I'll say that's also love in
substance may be that special
relationship carries a lot of you know
common values common goes and sheer
responsibility to achieve something
together and of course on the way great
enjoyment shared by both parties or even
more parties that's what I think what
love is or the rule it's a special
relationship with all these ingredients
yes do you think this is a simulation
even our reality reality
I think we we manipulate her said if you
use the word simulation I think that
that is kind of meaningful in a way
because the reality is what we perceive
so we already intervene the real reality
if there is one out say using simulation
is perhaps not a bad were not completely
wrong put it that way and simulation
trying to relate this almost to my word
out say it's kind of accurate because
when I try to simulate the the processes
for example right they seem to be rules
I have applied strictly but the result
the simulation result I could be
subjected to errors you know at the very
low level but could be subjected to even
the very basis of the models I'm not
trying to challenge those conservation
laws but certainly for a lot of models
we also need to conceptualize how the
system may functions what's involved
right and I'll say our perceptions our
understanding of the reality is a bit
like that
it's a modeling process perhaps with
some truth
in nerd but taken science as an example
right
they are hypothesis hypothesis tested
but even from the history we know test
it only we then constrain off whatever
technology at the time whatever capacity
we have whatever knowledge we have at
the time so I would say simulation is
perhaps not a bad word to describe it
yeah
and last question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
most beautiful thing
hmm I see beauties in a lot of things
but the most a beautiful one like I even
appreciate the beauty of waters and so
on in different ways but the most
beautiful thing maybe we can go back to
the word love a special relationship you
develop with a lot of things including
the family of course so yeah it could be
because you asked for one single beauty
and the most I'll say love but love
interpret in you know that very general
way it's a it's a special relationship
you have or you develop with you know
the family but also what you do and and
and so on and the nature of course we
have a beautiful relationship with the
nature yeah thank you so much this
natural relationship of the horse yeah
from the interview from this you know
encounters and and so yeah yeah thank
you so much for coming on our showing
and for teaching us about environment
hydrology so thank you thank you so
enlightening thank you thank you
everyone for tuning and we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about
environmental hydrology about the
relationship between the ocean land
interface and interactions about this
idea of groundwater discharge about the
global hydrological cycle in general the
analysis of these return flows about all
the different things that we talked
about catchment hydrology about dams
about how to maximize our prosperity on
the planet with our environment all
together and also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the organizations the
leaders around the world that you
believe and support them and help them
grow you can support simulation our
links are below help us continue doing
cool things
like coming on site to Westlake
University and interviewing great people
like Ling and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world you love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we'll see you soon
peace that's a wrap good job that was
awesome that was such a feelin that was
such a fun okay same for me
[Music]
you
[Music]